for more information on tutoring or how
to support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so we mentioned that Schrodinger
developed an equation and it was
specifically called schrödinger's wave
equation which is actually shown here
now this is kind of a simplified form
there are much more complicated versions
of schrödinger's wave equation but it's
the simplest form and we don't really
need to know all the details but here we
have this little H with a little hat
above it and then we have the Greek
letter s' I equals E times the Greek
letter sign so what are these things and
what do they represent the h of the hat
above it is the Hamiltonian operator
that really is is just a bunch of math
operations that for a general chemistry
student you really don't need to know
all the details of I don't to be on its
own we know them they're not really
important for general chemistry the e
represents the atoms energy and the
symbol side of the Greek letter sy
represents a wave function and a wave
function describes an electrons location
in 3d
I put the word kind of here because it's
not exactly like that okay so there are
a bunch of solutions to schrödinger's
wave equation and these solutions are
characterized by a wave function sy and
that sy has those different solutions
those different wave functions have
particular energy values now if you're
thinking about a specific wave function
a specific wave function is an atomic
orbital okay now a little note here some
people hear that word orbital and they
think orbit like in Bohr's model and
that is something you should not do that
they're very very different things
when we talked about Bohr's model we
talked about an orbit being a very
specific path around an atom's nucleus
that an electron would travel right a
very specific path but we saw with
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
that we can't exactly know the location
of an electron so the idea that it
travels in a very specific path is not
really something we could say so an
atomic orbital instead actually is
something very different and it doesn't
actually have a physical meaning which
is kind of weird okay so that kind of
brings me to this next point so even
though an orbital or wavefunction sigh
has no real physical meaning its square
size squared is the probability density
probability density okay
so what's that the probability density
is a measure of the probability or
likelihood that an electron will occupy
a certain region of space in an atom
okay so it just gives us the likelihood
of where an electron might be in an atom
so these probability densities can be
depicted in electron probability density
diagrams which is what the next video is
about okay so basically what's happening
here we're talking about Schrodinger's
equation wave functions in atomic
orbital so essentially we start with
Schrodinger wave equation and that is
solved and the solutions give you the
wave functions or the orbitals okay and
if we square the wave function or the
orbital we square it we get the
probability density of an electron okay
again which tells us the likelihood that
an electron electron will occupy a
certain region of space in an atom okay
so I hope that video is helpful with a
sort of overview of what's going on with
short energy equation and how that
applies to wave functions in the atomic
orbitals so we'll see what's going on in
these electron probability density
diagrams in the next video so I hope
that video was helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying